und da die Einzelpläne dann heute
Nachmittag sozusagen in Gänze mit dem
Entwurf das Haushaltsgesetzes überwiesen
werden in die Ausschüsse geht das jetzt
ganz schnell weiter zum letzten
Einzelplan in dieser haushaltswoche und
hier steht das der Etat des Ministeriums
für Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend
auf der Tagesordnung die zuständige
Ministerin heißt alle Spiegel kommt von
den Grünen der Entwurf will kommen jetzt
gerade von Arbeit und Soziales dem
größten Etat 160 Milliarden Ausgaben für
2022 geplant im Vergleich dazu bei
Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend 12
Milliarden Ausgaben für 2022 geplant
also eine der kleineren Etagen
Bundeshaushalt der größte Einzelposten
übrigens ist das Elterngeld hier sind
alleine 7,7 Milliarden Euro eingeplant
und schlagen zu Buche eingespart werden
soll bei der Kinder- und Jugendpolitik
das wird sicher hier ja Aussprache ein
Thema werden aber jetzt erstmal die
Ministerin Anne Spiegel zu ihrem
Einzelplan
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Abgeordnete und zuhörende
am Dienstag war ich mit Rabbiner
Teichtal in einer Flüchtlingsunterkunft
am Kudamm dort haben jüdische
Waisenkinder und jüdische Frauen mit
ihren Kindern aus der Ukraine eine
Bleibe gefunden sie alle stammen aus
Odessa mich hat beeindruckt mit welcher
Herzlichkeit sie dort betreut werden das
jüngste Kind war gerade einmal acht
Wochen alt es hat noch ein ganzes Leben
vor sich es ist jetzt in Sicherheit und
gestern war ich gemeinsam mit der
Vorsitzenden von SOS-Kinderdorf
Deutschland Frau Professorin Schutter in
einem SOS-Kinderdorf und habe dort mit
ukrainischen Frauen und ihren Kindern
gesprochen
einerseits ihren Schmerz ihre
Traumatisierung durch den Krieg
und die dramatische Flucht zu spüren
aber andererseits auch die Erleichterung
nun hier in Sicherheit zu sein und die
Hoffnung begann in dem Moment als sie am
Bahnhof in Berlin ein Mitarbeiter mit
sos-kinderdorfweste sein für diese
Hoffnung in Sicherheit zu sein und hier
schnell und unbürokratisch aufgenommen
zu werden danke ich
stellvertretend vor allen die sich Haupt
und ehrenamtlich engagieren
sos-teichtal es ist großartig denn hier
wird ganz schnell geholfen sie mindern
leid und sie geben Hoffnung
das Bundesfamilienministerium hilft ganz
konkret wir stehen bereit die
Koordinierung für die evakuierten
weisenhäuser zu übernehmen mir ist es
sehr wichtig dass wir für diese Kinder
die ohne Eltern sind und die so viel
Leid und Tod erlebt haben so viel
Geborgenheit und Stabilität wie möglich
schaffen dazu gehört dass sie in ihren
Vertrauten Gruppen zusammen bleiben
können und dass sie nicht von ihren
betreuer:innen getrennt werden das
Konzept für die Koordinierungsstelle
liegt vor und wir haben starke
Partnerinnen an unserer Seite die
Koordinierungsstelle soll Ordnung
schaffen und Anlaufstelle sein und wir
schauen genau hin was diese Menschen
jetzt brauchen die aus der Ukraine zu
uns kommen und dazu zählt auch der
entschlossene Kampf gegen skrupellose
Menschenhändler Zuhälter und
Sexualstraftäter die die verzweifelte
Lage von Frauen und Kindern ausnutzen
wollen
unsere
Expertinnen unsere Expertinnen vom
Koordinierungskreis gegen Menschenhandel
vom hilfetelefon Gewalt gegen Frauen und
der Hotline des Unabhängigen
Beauftragten für Fragen des sexuellen
Kindesmissbrauchs Arbeiten Seite an
Seite mit den Polizeibehörden es gibt
psychosoziale Unterstützung und unsere
bewährten Sprach- und Integrationskurse
beispielsweise diejenigen für Mütter
gleichzeitig mit Kinderbetreuung stehen
all jenen beiseite damit diese ersten
Schritte der Integration des
Spracherwerbs und der Teilhabe jetzt
schnell und unbürokratisch begonnen
werden können
sehr geehrte Abgeordnete der Einzelplan
17 den wir heute einbringen es steht für
Hilfe für Förderung und für
Unterstützung für alle Kinder und ihre
Familien in der Bundesrepublik und der
größte Posten finanziert die bekannteste
und beliebteste Familienleistung in
Deutschland das Elterngeld dafür stehen
7,73 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung
erhilft Müttern und Vätern Beruf und
Familie noch besser zu vereinbaren und
zuletzt haben 42 Prozent der Väter
Elterngeld in Anspruch genommen mit
einer durchschnittlichen Bezugsdauer von
3,7 Monaten das ist eine sehr gute
Entwicklung und darauf wollen wir auch
aufbauen und wir werden
Frau Ministerin Entschuldigung gestatten
sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Zwischenbemerkung aus der afd-fraktion
nein ich möchte danke
wir werden Familien weiter entlasten mit
dem Aufbau einer Kindergrundsicherung
und damit das in seiner Komplexität gut
funktioniert gibt es unter unserer
Leitung eine interministeriale
Arbeitsgruppe kurzfristig entlasten wir
von Juli an bedürftige Familien mit dem
sofortzuschlag damit gibt es zusätzlich
20 Euro pro Kind pro Monat beim
Kinderzuschlag und ich bin sehr froh
dass auch geflüchtete Kinder aus der
Ukraine diesen Kinder sofortzuschlag
bekommen
die Bundesregierung unterstützt Familien
auf vielfältige Weise sei es beim ersten
Entlastungspaket denn natürlich hilft es
auch Familien wenn es
inhaltskostenzuschuss gibt oder das
Kurzarbeitergeld aber auch mit dem
zweiten Entlastungspaket helfen wir
Familien durch einen einmalbonus von 100
Euro pro Kind und zusätzlich zum
Kindergeld und weiteren 100 Euro für
allen die Sozialleistungen beziehen ein
wichtiges Plus im Geldbeutel für
Familien in der aktuellen Lage und wir
bleiben dabei nicht stehen
ein weiterer Schwerpunkt ist das
Aktionsprogramm aufholen nach Corona für
Kinder und Jugendliche für das wir 272
Millionen Euro bereitstellen aber
natürlich auch wichtige Mittel um die
Gleichberechtigung voranzutreiben um
Frauen vor Gewalt zu schützen um Kinder
vor sexualisierter Gewalt und Missbrauch
zu schützen um queere Menschen zu
stärken um trans-menschen die von
Anfeindung betroffen sind zu stärken und
wir werden Seniorinnen unter anderem
durch den digitalpakt-alter Stärken und
die Situation von Pflegebedürftigen
verbessern und wir haben eine Strategie
gegen Einsamkeit gestartet es gilt auch
die Folgen von Corona im Blick zu halten
[Applaus]
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren die
Folgen des ukrainekrieges sie fordern
entschlossenes Handeln für Waisenkinder
für unbegleitete Minderjährige für
Frauen für über 60-Jährige und ein
besonderes Augenmerk gilt den
Hochbetagten Holocaust Überlebende ich
will dass sie alle einen sicheren Hafen
in Deutschland haben das ist unsere
Verantwortung mehr als dass das ist
unsere humanitäre Verpflichtung und für
mich ist aber auch klar es gibt keine
Flüchtlinge erster und zweiter Klasse
und eng damit verknüpft ist unser
entschlossenes Engagement gegen
Rassismus gegen Antiziganismus gegen
Antisemitismus durch die Mittel von
Demokratie leben meine Damen und Herren
meine Damen und Herren nie war es
wichtiger als jetzt nie war es wichtiger
als jetzt entschlossen für die
Demokratie und demokratische Werte
einzutreten in Deutschland aber auch
international und als jugendministerin
stehe ich dafür dass die junge
Generation in einer vielfältigen
Demokratie geprägt von Solidarität und
Respekt aufwachsen kann wir alle haben
es in der Hand wir alle sind gefragt für
diese demokratischen Werte einzutreten
danke schön
eine Spiegel war das die
Bundesfamilienministerin hier einleitend
zu ihrem etaya einiges was im Haushalt
steht hat sie genannt einiges an
Vorhaben
noch nicht angeschoben ein zentrales
Projekt der Ampel die Kinder
Grundsicherung gestern hat eine Spiegel
in einem Interview gesagt eine
Arbeitsgruppe dazu werdet sehr zeitnah
an den Start gehen heute hat man was
gehört von einer
interministeriellen Arbeitsgruppe also
das wird man mit Sicherheit in den
nächsten Wochen im Auge behalten auch
hier im Parlament Silvia Praia jetzt für
die cdu/csu-fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Frau Ministerin Spiegel ihre
Koalition hat einen zukunftsjahrzehn
versprochen aber wo ist ihr zukunftsjahr
10 für die Familien und vor allen Dingen
für die junge Generation für unsere
Kinder denn dieser Haushalt dieser
Haushalt den wir in dieser Woche
vorstellen der ist vor allen Dingen eins
ein Vertrag zu Lasten Dritter ein
Vertrag auf Kosten unserer Kinder und
deshalb müsste doch zumindest mehr drin
sein mehr drin sein für unsere Kinder
der Haushalt des bärenfsfj lag beim
Amtsantritt von Angela Merkel bei 4,5
Milliarden Euro und hat sich in ihrer
Regierungszeit bis 2021 fast
verdreifacht auf
13,2 Milliarden Euro und jetzt sind wir
im Jahr 22 nach zwei Jahren Corona
inmitten der größten flüchtlingskrise
der Blick auf Familie auf Frauen Kinder
und Jugend ist wie nie zuvor und jetzt
kommen sie Frau Ministerin Spiegel und
erstmals singt der Etat ihres
Haus 12,6 Milliarden Euro um eine halbe
millionende versprochen sie haben eine
Zeitenwende versprochen wir haben uns
das etwas anders vorgestellt Frau breher
Entschuldigung
keine Zwischenfrage wenn Sie uns also
nun bitte konkret und aktuell werden
lassen Frau Ministerin Spiegel
Bundesfamilienministerin wo sind sie wo
sind sie gewesen für all die
geflüchteten Frauen und Kinder aus der
Ukraine sie halten hier heute eine
empathische Rede für sie fordern den
Schutz für die Kinder und für die Frauen
ein sie fordern ein entschlossenes
Handeln ein aber wochenlang dreieinhalb
Wochen bis Dienstag zu einem
öffentlichen Pressetermin haben wir von
ihnen nichts
diesem Thema Frauen und Kinder aus der
Ukraine
[Applaus]
sie fordern ein aber sie sind
Bundesregierung und von ihnen hätte ich
Antworten erwartet wie wollen sie den
Schutz der Frauen und Kinder vor
zwangsprostitutionen und Ausbeutung
sicherstellen welche Angebote
sie wie sollen die ukrainischen Kinder
integriert werden und vor allen Dingen
wo finde ich diese Ideen in ihrem
Haushalt das sind die nämlich
[Applaus]
an
viel versprochen die Koalitionsvertrag
ist eine große Wunschliste und auch sie
haben im Januar hier eine Reihe Ideen
vorgestellt aber die finde ich auch mit
einer Lupe in ihrem Haushalt nicht bei
ihnen in der Koalition stehen die
Familien einfach an letzter Stelle im
Januar haben sie prioritär die Reform
der Elterngeld Lösungen angekündigt mit
zweiwöchigen
Freistellung nach der Geburt Elterngeld
für Pflegeeltern in ihrem Haushalt ist
nichts dafür eingestellt und dann ihr
großes Versprechen die Kinder
Grundsicherung aus dem sofortzuschlag
haben sie das sofort gestrichen es kommt
erst im Sommer und 20 Euro sind übrig
geblieben aber die eigentliche
Kindergrundsicherung die eigentliche
Kindergrundsicherung sie richten den
Arbeitskreis ein und wollen den in
dieser Legislatur schaffen dann haben
wir uns die Eckwerte angeschaut weder in
ihrem Haushalt noch in dem Haushalt a&s
sind die Eckwerte für die
Kindergrundsicherung hinterlegt an
keiner einzigen Stelle
und was ist mit einem weiteren
Investitionsprogramm für die
kinderbetreuungsausbau wir haben eine
Schrift
liche Union gestellt sie haben
geantwortet sie würden ein Konzept
ausarbeiten aber warum ist dein ein
weiteres
Investitionsprogramm für die
kinderbetreuungsausbau weder 22 noch in
der langfristigen Finanzplanung ihres
Hauses enthalten warum denn die
Antragsfrist für unser aus unserer
Regierungszeit fünftes
Investitionsprogramm läuft Mitte diesen
Jahres aus also diese Bundesregierung
stellt für einen Ausbau der
Kinderbetreuung im Haushalt kein Geld
zur Verfügung und wo wir schon beim
Thema sind sie haben versprochen die
gute Kitas gute Kita-Gesetz was Ende
diesen Jahres ausläuft in ein
qualitätsentwicklungsgesetz
vorzuentwickeln
nur und ja sie ahnen es schon liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Länder
achten Sie mal genau darauf im Jahr 2023
in den Eck werden sind keine Mittel für
ein gutes Kita-Gesetz eingestellt wir
eine Fortführung des guter kita-gesetzes
sieht ihr Haushalt nicht vor
und in ihrer Rede führen sie aus und
loben das Aktionsprogramm aufholen nach
Corona ja das Programm ist richtig das
Programm ist wichtig und es ist gut es
ist nämlich von uns es ist unser
corona-aufholprogramm 2021 22 mit
insgesamt 2 Milliarden Euro aufgelegt
von der alten Bundesregierung was sie
jetzt vorfinanzieren Frau Ministerin in
ihrer Rede im Januar haben Sie ein neues
zukunftspaket aufholen nach Corona
angekündigt und was finden wir in den
Eckwerten 23
50 Millionen gegenüber zwei Milliarden
21 22 da erspar ich uns jetzt jeden
Kommentar und ich muss Ihnen sagen liebe
Koalitionäre liebe Frau Ministerin ich
kann jetzt verstehen das Lesen sie noch
nicht im Haus bei uns im Ausschuss
gewesen sind weil ihre Vorhaben 22 und
wir haben jetzt immerhin schon Ende März
die sind im Haushalt einfach nicht
hinterlegt sie halten ihre wir sprechen
nicht leider aus Sicht der Familie
müssen wir an dieser Stelle sagen und
wir hoffen dass sie dort erheblich
nachbessern werden damit sie ihre
Versprechen halten können vielen Dank
da harsche Kritik und harsche Angriffe
hier von Seiten der cdu/csu-fraktion
hier von Silvia breher der Sprecherin
für Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend
und während ihrer Rede gab es aber auch
diverse Zwischenrufe die man leider
nicht so gut hier über die Tonanlage
dann ja vermittelt verstehen kann
deswegen hören wir lieber was jetzt am
Rednerpult weiter passiert als
Erwiderung Elisabeth Kaiser für die SPD
der sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
entschuldigung aber Entschuldigung
frau
Kaiser hat jetzt überwiegend das Wort am
Rednerpult
vielen dank vielen Dank sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Frau
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrte MitbürgerInnen
Mitbürger seit zwei Jahren befinden wir
uns in einer Pandemie wir alle spüren
die Auswirkungen und sind Corona müden
besonders gelitten haben in dieser Zeit
Kinder Familien
ältere und pflegebedürftige Menschen und
die sie Pflegenden zu dieser jahrhundert
Herausforderung Corona kommt eine zweite
Krise die wir bis Februar nicht für
möglich hielten ein Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine ein Krieg in Europa
verbunden mit unheimlicher Zerstörung
tausenden Toten Vertreibung und Flucht
klar ist wir stehen an der Seite der
Ukraine einen Ukrainer und wir helfen
den geflüchteten wir werden dafür sorgen
dass ich vor allen Dingen Frauen Kinder
ältere und kranke Menschen die zu uns
kommen dass wir sie unkompliziert und
schnell aufnehmen
wir wollen gemeinsam mit den Ländern und
Kommunen dafür sorgen dass Sie sich bei
uns von den schlimmen Erlebnissen in
ihrer Heimat und der Flucht erholen
können und eine Unterkunft finden in der
sie sich sicher und geborgen fühlen
können liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir müssen in diesem Jahr nicht nur mit
den Folgen der Gesundheitskrise sondern
auch mit den Folgen des Krieges in der
Ukraine umgehen deshalb ist es umso
wichtiger für Stabilität sowie innerer
und soziale Sicherheit zu sorgen das tun
wir als Ampelkoalition mit diesem
Haushalt
wir werden dazu beitragen die Folgen der
Pandemie abzufedern mit den
ergänzungshaushalt werden wir auf die
Auswirkungen des ukraine-kriegs und den
steigenden nrw-preisen reagieren die
beschlossenen entlastungspakete werden
sich darin wiederfinden klar ist aber
auch dass wir die Ziele dieser Koalition
dabei nicht aus dem Blick verlieren wir
wollen unser Land in eine gute Zukunft
führen deshalb investieren wir in
Familien Kinder und Jugendliche wir
investieren in Gleichberechtigung und
Schutz für Frauen und Kinder und
Unterstützung für ältere Menschen und
den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt wir
wollen dass jede und jeder in
Deutschland die hier zu Hause nennen an
unserer Demokratie teilhaben und sich
sicher fühlen können
12,7 Milliarden Euro ist dieser Haushalt
des Bundesministeriums für Familie
Frauen Senioren Senioren und Jugend
schwer ich möchte anhand einiger Punkte
verdeutlichen wie die Koalition auf die
aktuellen Herausforderungen reagiert
dazu möchte ich zunächst auf diejenigen
aufmerksam machen die in den letzten
zwei Jahren viel zu wenig gehört worden
Kinder und Jugendliche in der Pandemie
haben sie besonders gelitten aber von
ihnen hat man am wenigsten gehört
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir Sie mit
diesem Haushalt besonders in den Fokus
nehmen wir wollen Ihnen die Möglichkeit
bieten versäumt es nachzuholen lernen
Lücken zu schließen und sie unterstützen
in ihr soziales Leben zurückzufinden
dafür starten wir das aus
Aktionsprogramm aufholen nach Corona mit
mehr als 272 Millionen Euro aus damit
finanzieren wir unter anderem
Lernangebote sowie Sport- und
Freizeitaktivitäten
mit Blick auf die corona-pandemie und
ihre Auswirkungen auf die Entwicklung
unserer Kinder bin ich sehr froh dass
wir Programme wie sprachkitas und
kita-einstieg in diesem Jahr auf
stärkerem Niveau fördern wollen
besonders Kindern aus bildungsfernen
Familien und Familien mit
Migrationshintergrund profitieren von
den zusätzlichen fachpädagoginnen und
Pädagogen in den Kitas und ich bin dafür
ein überzeugt dass wir hier in der
richtigen Stelle Geld in die Hand nehmen
nicht nur weil ich einige dieser
Einrichtungen in Thüringen besuchen
konnte sondern auch weil ich davon
überzeugt bin das Sprache das wichtigste
Tor zur gesellschaftlichen Teilhabe ist
und auch an anderer Stelle unterstützen
wir die Förderung von Kindern und
Jugendlichen Haushalt herisch wir wollen
die Mittel des Kinder- und jugendplans
erhöhen das wichtigste Förderinstrument
auf Bundesebene im Bereich der Kinder
und Jugendhilfe mit dem März 30
Millionen Euro an zusätzlichen Mitteln
unterstützen wir die Rechte von Kindern
und Jugendlichen auf Schutz Förderung
und Beteiligung für einen
gleichberechtigten Zusammenhalt lebendig
wird diese Förderung durch enge
Kooperationen mit Ländern Kommunen und
den Trägern der Kinder und Jugendhilfe
und als Mitglied der Naturfreunde
Thüringen der Landesvereinigung
kulturelle Jugendbildung Thüringen aber
eben auch als Schwester eines
Sozialarbeiters in meiner Heimatstadt
Gera da weiß ich wie wichtig diese
Förderung ist und wir sehr sie vor Ort
gebraucht wird
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
möchte einen hier persönlich sehr
wichtiges Anliegen ansprechen was auch
die Ministerin betont hat nämlich die
demokratie-förderung die
Zivilgesellschaft ist so ein
unverzichtbarer Teil unserer Demokratie
und unserer Kommunen wir wollen den
Menschen den Rücken stärken die für
unsere Demokratie Gesicht und Mut zeigen
denn sie füllen die Städte und Gemeinden
mit Leben für die Stärkung von
von Vielfalt Toleranz und Demokratie ist
für 2022 die Rekordsumme von mehr als
183 Millionen Euro eingestellt davon
allein 165,5 Millionen Euro für das
Programm Demokratie die Demokratie leben
das sind 15 Millionen Euro mehr im
Vergleich zum letzten Jahr und damit ist
das Programm Demokratie leben die
wesentlich zu Unterstützung der
Zivilgesellschaft eine Demokratie
Förderung
mit dem
mit dem Programm stärken und helfen wir
allen Menschen die dich tagtäglich für
unsere Demokratie einsetzen und sich
mutig rechtsextremen und anderen
formengruppenbezogener
Menschenfeindlichkeit entgegenstellen
das Engagement ist nicht
selbstverständlich und dafür möchte ich
an dieser Stelle ganz herzlich Danke
sagen danke Ihnen und Euch für Euren
Einsatz
und ich freue mich ich freue mich
wirklich sehr dass die
bundesministerinnen Nancy Feser und eine
Spiegel noch in diesem Jahr gemeinsam
das Demokratie fördergesetz vorstellen
wollen mit dem das Engagement dass sie
die Gesellschaft auf eine verlässliche
und planbare Basis gestellt wird das
sind genau das sind die Signale an die
hier engagierten und ich bin mir sicher
und arbeite gerne daran mit dass dieses
grundlagengesetz nachhaltig wirkt und an
dieser Stelle möchte ich auch die
zusätzlichen Mittel für die Deutsche
Stiftung für Ehrenamt und Engagement
erwähnen die noch relativ junger
Stiftung ist mit dem Anspruch angetreten
dass Ehrenamt und Engagement vor allem
in den strukturschwachen und ländlichen
Räumen zu unterstützen und als
Thüringerin muss ich leider immer noch
sagen dass der Förderschwerpunkt damit
vor allem in ostdeutschen Bundesländern
liegt dass die Stiftung ihrem Anspruch
vielleicht Kollegen ist ein Moment liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist jetzt
aber auch ein bisschen misslich neben
Diskussionen zu führen vielleicht
lassen wir erstmal die Rednerin reden
und dann können sie ja auch in ihren
Debatten Beiträgen noch darauf eingehen
bitte schön vielen Dank frau Präsidentin
ich war bei der Stiftung für Ehrenamt
und Engagement und möchte sagen dass die
Stiftung ihren Anspruch gerecht geworden
ist ich kann nicht aus eigener Erfahrung
als lokale Abgeordnete sagen aber eben
auch als Mitglied im Stiftungsrat noch
auf den Krieg in der Ukraine hat sich
schnell reagiert Online-Informationen
veröffentlicht sowohl für Hilfen
Suchende als auch für Menschen die sich
ehrenamtlich einbringen wollen damit die
Stiftung auch zukünftig ihr Engagement
und all seiner breiter unterstützen kann
ist es wichtig sie auch weiterhin
auskömmlich zu finanzieren und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt in
diesem Haushalt noch viel gutes und
wichtiges was ich wegen der Redezeit
auch noch schlagartig nennen kann
erwähnt sein die Maßnahmen für den
Schutz für vor Gewalt für Frauen und
Kinder dass wir diese sichern und
stärken wir stärken die Bundesstiftung
Gleichstellung geben den Diensten den
Freiwilligendiensten Planungssicherheit
und unterstützen die Wohlfahrtsverbände
ihrer wichtigen Arbeit und mit dem
Kinder sofortzuschlag sorgen wir dafür
dass 2,9 Millionen armutsgefährte die
Kinder und Jugendliche bessere Chancen
auf gesellschaftliche Teilhabe haben und
gleichzeitig gehen wir damit den ersten
Schritt in eine Kindergrundsicherung
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
sind das sind in diesem Jahr meine
ersten Haushaltsberatungen und
hinsichtlich der aktuellen Situation in
Europa sicherlich auch keine einfachen
wenn wir aber Fortschritt in Deutschland
reden wenn wir davon reden dann ist es
mir wichtig dass wir alle Menschen für
alle Menschen einbeziehen die in diesem
Land leben in Zeiten des schnellen
Wandels und der Veränderungen wollen wir
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern Sicherheit
geben der vorliegende Haushalt ist für
uns Abgeordnete dafür eine gute
Grundlage aber sie ist sicherlich auch
immer verbesserungswürdig und deshalb
freue ich mich auf die weiteren
Beratungen ich danke ihnen sagt
Elisabeth Kaiser für die SPD-Fraktion ja
und während ihrer Rede ging es im
Nachgang hier zu der Rede von Silvia
breher von der CDU doch noch zwischen
grünen und Silvia breher hin und her
ohne Chance von den Grünen auf Britta
Hasselmann die
Fraktionsvorsitzende waren noch mal in
den Reihen der Union und haben mit
Sylvia preher gesprochen die ja scharfe
Kritik geäußert hatte
aber vielleicht kann man das dann am
Rednerpult bei den nächsten Rednern wenn
hier grün und CDU auch noch mal zu Wort
kommen dann noch mal thematisieren
Martin Reichert hören wir jetzt für die
AFD
der diesjährige Haushalt wird erstmals
in erhebliche Maße von Feministen
verantwortet feministische
Familienpolitik steht im Zeichen des
schissmus der spiegelismus ist die
Endstufe des feministischen Egoismus und
erlebte einen traurigen Höhepunkt
während der Flutkatastrophe im Ahrtal
als feministischem Egoismus auch
Menschenleben in großer Zahl zum Opfer
fielen meine Damen und Herren ihr Motto
Frau Spiegel wen Scheren die Toten
hauptsache das Image stimmt
der spigilismus führt wie sie Frau
Spiegel zeigen in eine täteropfer Umkehr
die jede Ungerechtigkeit gegen in eine
die jede Kritik in eine Ungerechtigkeit
gegen die eigene Person umdeutet der
spiegelismus verhindert dass sie Frau
Ministerin durch Rücktritt wenigstens
Reste von Anstand zeigen sie aber kleben
an ihrem Stuhl als Schandmaul ihres
Charakters und als Katastrophe für
Familien
im feminist in feministischer Nabelschau
ist es nicht verwunderlich dass die
demografische Katastrophe keine
Erwähnung im Haushalt findet und auch
keine Geburten fördernde Politik
stattfindet obwohl der demograf die
demografische Katastrophe mit einem
bestandsverlust
der einheimischen Bevölkerung von 25
Prozent von Generationen zu Generation
unser Land und unsere Sozialsysteme
existenziell bedroht meine Damen und
Herren
die großen Posten dieses Haushalts
Elterngeld 7,7 Milliarden Kinderzuschlag
1,37 Milliarden und Unterhaltsvorschuss
eine Milliarde bleiben nahezu
unverändert politisch bleibt es aber bei
der Linken Tradition kümmerlichste
Initiativen mit klingenden Namen zu
versehen
aktuellstes Beispiel der Kinder
sofortzuschlag von 20 Euro im Monat das
sind einige Liter Diesel die sie da
spendieren der mit dem Namen Kinder
verhöhnungszuschlag sicherlich besser
beschrieben worden wäre
aber auch hier sorgt der spiegelismus
mit der Wirtschaftspolitik des als gutem
Feministen bekannten Herrn Habeck für
ganz neue Perversionen Feministen haben
durch gewaltige Teuerungsraten bei
Lebensmitteln Energie Kraftstoffen die
existenznotärmerer Familien und auch von
Frauen dramatisch verschärft und das
gilt es hier festzustellen
Herr Habeck schuf so die Grundlage auf
der sich der feministische Egoismus der
Ministerin erneut entfalten kann
Familien in Not bilden nämlich für
diesen Egoismus nur ein Bühnenbild wie
es auch schon die Ereignisse im Ahrtal
gebildet haben warum Frau Spiegel sie
wissen ganz genau dass weder die jetzt
angekündigten mickrigen Entlastungen
noch die geplante Kindergrundsicherung
und schon gar nicht der Kinder
sofortzuschlag die Folgen feministischer
Politik und die daraus entstandene
Teuerungswelle für die Menschen auch nur
annähernd ausgleichen können
diese Wahrheit aber verschweigen sie den
Menschen sie verschweigen sie deshalb
weil sie sich insbesondere für die
Kinder Grundsicherung der einst noch als
Retterin der Armen und Unterstützerin
feiern lassen wollen das ist unehrlich
und ihr Motto ihr Motto lautet letzten
Endes wieder wen schert die Verarmung
von Kindern und Familien hauptsache mein
Image stimmt meine Damen und Herren
zur feministischen Imagepflege zählen
auch Millionen von Euro die in Bund und
Land für gleichstellungspropaganda
ausgegeben werden was wurde nicht hier
im Plenum schon alles verkündet
feministische Politik sichert ein
friedliches Zusammenleben feministische
Politik sorgt für mehr soziale
Gerechtigkeit Frauen können alles das
Patriarchat und die Männer sind schuld
an aller Ungleichheit allen swiss-
das ist aber das ist aber die Politik
ausgewiesener Feministen ist die Armut
von Familien und damit auch von Frauen
hervorbringt wird ebenso verschwiegen
wie die Tatsache dass es eine
feministische Verteidigungsministerin
und Außenministerin ist die nachdem ihre
Parteien das Militär seit Jahrzehnten
verhöhnt haben jetzt plötzlich bei
locket Martin shoppen gehen wollen und
dort sogar Atombomber einkaufen möchten
meine Damen und Herren und um das um das
alles zu finanzieren hat man nicht etwa
die Kreditkarte mitgenommen sondern man
hat sich ein Sondervermögen von 100
Milliarden Euro in die Tasche gesteckt
meine Damen und Herren
und wenn wir dann das feministische
Motto hier ansehen dann können wir
folgendes sagen was stören uns Armut und
Atomkrieg hauptsache das Image stimmt
das war so und das bleibt so
am Schluss am Schluss meine Damen und
Herren müssen nur noch alle Kritiker
dieses ganzen Irrsinns mundtot gemacht
werden und das geschieht durch die
massive Förderung des sogenannten
Kampfes gegen Rechts jeder der heute dem
Irrsinn der Feminismus gesteuerten Ampel
widerspricht wird mit Totschlag
Begriffen diffamiert
klimaleugner corona-leugner
frauenfeindlich transfeindlich
ausländerfeindlich neuerdings in Mode
putinversteher und der Dauerbrenner
rechtsextrem das sind die Schlagworte
mit denen Sie andere Meinungen kaputt
machen meine Damen und Herren
und dann gilt der Mensch eben als rechts
und fällt dem
oppositionsbekämpfungsprogramm zum Opfer
das mit 165 Millionen ausgestattet ist
und verlogener Weise Demokratie leben
heißt meine Damen und Herren
das feministische Motto lautet in diesem
Zusammenhang wer an unserem Image kratzt
der muss eben weg Heinz Rudolf Kunze hat
einmal gesagt traut keinem Sänger ich
rufe ihnen zu traut keinem Feministen
und seiner Politik denn wer männlichen
Chauvinismus zu Recht kritisiert der
muss es eben auch mit feministischem tun
auch wenn er von Frau Ministerin Spiegel
kommt vielen Dank
Abgeordneter reichert die harte
Auseinandersetzung in der Sache ist
absolut angebracht und ist hier ja auch
gewollt ich muss aber ganz zum Anfang
ihrer Rede noch mal zurückkommen ich
denke dass man
Opfer von solchen schweren Ereignissen
wie der Flutkatastrophe hier nicht
instrumentalisieren sollte um die eigene
Meinung rüberzubringen ich sage Ihnen
das jetzt
ja Sie können sich das ja auch mal
anhören
[Applaus]
ich habe sie auf etwas aufmerksam
gemacht und sie können ja vielleicht mal
drei Sekunden darüber nachdenken
als nächste Rednerin in dieser Debatte
und wenn sie noch ihre Maske bitte
wieder aufsetzen würden als nächste
Rednerin in dieser Debatte bekommt
Claudia raffelhüchen für die FDP das
Wort
[Applaus]
also es ist ja erfreulich dass alle so
wach sind aber jetzt hören wir der
Rednerin Frau raffelhüchen zu
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich habe jetzt hier schon
mehrmals gesagt wer das aber gerne
nochmals wiederholen auf meiner
politischen Agenda steht das Wohl
unserer Kinder ganz oben sie und die
folgenden Generationen sollen nicht wie
Sisyphos vor einem Schuldenberg stehen
den wir teils aus Not teils aus
Bequemlichkeit aufgehäuft haben sondern
sie sollen in jeder Hinsicht auch
wirtschaftlich die nötigen Freiräume
haben sich zu entwickeln und ihre
persönlichen Lebensziele erreichen
können das und genau das ist
Nachhaltigkeit im haushaltsrechtlichen
Kontext
zum Einzelplan 17 passt das natürlich
ganz hervorragend nirgends geht es so um
die Zukunft unseres Landes wie hier
unsere kinder sind unsere Zukunft das
klingt ziemlich banal und abgedroschen
ja man muss es aber immer wiederholen
aber das macht es nicht weniger richtig
oder relevant fakt ist die
corona-pandemie hat die globalen
Probleme auf geradezu schwindeln
erregende Weise verschärft fakt ist aber
auch dass die Pandemie in Deutschland
auf ein extrem Reiches gut entwickeltes
Land getroffen ist und wir vieles besser
überstanden haben als andere Länder
dennoch sind auch bei uns große und man
muss es leider so sagen
vermeidbare Schäden entstanden
finanzielle materielle gesundheitliche
und seelische und die hauptleitragenden
Waren aus meiner Sicht die
frauenfamilien und insbesondere die
Kinder
niemanden wurde so viel zugemutet wie
ihn und das obwohl in der Entwicklung
eines Kindes ein Jahr geschweige denn
zwei oder drei Jahre buchstäblich Welten
sind in denen so unglaublich viel
passiert und die sich nicht mal eben so
nachholen lassen wie ein Urlaub ein
Projekt oder eine Fortbildung über deren
Ausfall wir als Erwachsene und schon
genug geärgert haben
nachdem wir nun als über zwei Jahre lang
durchaus zurecht von Kindern und
Familien Solidarität und Opfer gefordert
haben und diese Opfer wurden weit
überwiegend mit großen Verständnis und
toller Disziplin gebracht ist es nun an
der Zeit Ihnen eine ganze Menge
zurückzugeben und die Kinder wieder in
das Zentrum unserer Aufmerksamkeit zu
stellen
mit umkomplizierter Unterstützung mit
einem wertschätzenden Blick auf das was
Familien sind und für unsere
Gesellschaft leisten und natürlich auch
mit Haushaltsmitteln ich bin daher sehr
froh dass im Regierungsentwurf für
unseren Einzelplan noch einmal
272 Millionen Euro zusätzliche Mittel im
corona-aufholprogramm Stehen von denen
der größte Teil Kindern Jugendlichen und
familienzukommen und auch wenn es
mitunter fast schon negativ dargestellt
wird dass der Großteil des Einzelplan 17
in gesetzlichen Leistungen gebunden und
daher nicht zu flexibel einsetzbar ist
muss man doch festhalten dass diese
gesetzlichen Leistungen wie Elterngeld
oder der Kinderzuschlag eine ganze Menge
bewirken und gerade auch während der
Pandemie für Millionen Familien
unverzichtbare Hilfen waren und
finanzielle Stabilität bedeuten
wenn das ein ganz normales familienleber
Leben auch im 21 Jahrhundert und sogar
in Europa keine Selbstverständlichkeit
ist wurde uns jetzt durch den Krieg in
der Ukraine nochmals ganz brutal vor
Augen geführt die Kinder von
zurückbleibenden Vätern und ihren
Flüchtenden Frauen und Kindern sind
nicht zu ertragen viele von ihnen suchen
bei uns in Deutschland Schutz und finden
ihn glücklicherweise auch die
Hilfsbereitschaft der ehrenamtlichen
Helfer ist beeindruckend aber sie
alleine wird nicht ausreichen auch Bund
und Länder sind gefragt und diese neue
zusätzliche große Aufgabe im Bereich der
Familienpolitik zu stemmen es ist daher
in jeder Hinsicht richtig dass wir im
Regierungsentwurf wieder mehr als 2,5
Milliarden Euro für den Einzelplan 17
vorsehen die Aufgaben in diesem Bereich
sind gigantisch und die Ausgaben sind
Investitionen in die Zukunft unserer
Familien und unsere sozialen
Zusammenleben in all seinen Facetten
vielen Dank
claudia raffelhirschen war das für die
FDP-Fraktion sie sitzt im
Haushaltsausschuss
und wenn Sie hier heute morgen die
Beratung schon länger verfolgen haben
Sie gemerkt dass sie heute so schon zum
zweiten Mal gesprochen hat genauso
übrigens wie die nächste Rednerin die
schon mehrfach in dieser Woche
gesprochen hat Gesine lötz für die Linke
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
und auch zuständig für Haushalt
meine Damen und Herren jedes fünfte Kind
in Deutschland gilt als armutsgefährdet
so die Antwort der Bundesregierung auf
einer Anfrage meiner Fraktion das sind
fast drei Millionen Kinder und
Jugendliche in unserem reichen Land das
ist beschämend dass diskriminiert und
mindert Lebenschancen so darf das nicht
weitergehen
und es ist auch nicht nur zutiefst
ungerecht sondern es schadet der
gesamten Gesellschaft denn große soziale
Unterschiede sind schlecht für die
Entwicklungschancen der gesamten
Gesellschaft daran muss man immer wieder
erinnern
Frau Ministerin Spiegel sie sprachen
über die Kindergrundsicherung ich kann
Ihnen nur sagen es eilt wenn die
Bundesregierung bzw die Koalition mit
Unterstützung der Union quasi über Nacht
ein Sondervermögen Aufrüstung von 100
Milliarden Euro beschließen kann dann
muss es doch auch möglich sein innerhalb
eines Jahres die Kindergrundsicherung zu
verabschieden meine Damen und Herren
die Diakonie hat berechnet dass Kinder
in der Grundsicherung monatlich 78 Euro
zu wenig erhalten das fehlt für Essen
für Kleidung für Freizeitaktivitäten und
das ist ungerecht
nun sollen die Kinder 20 Euro im Monat
bekommen und der Finanzminister war
nicht bereit ihn mehr zuzugestehen sie
dürfen sich Frau Spiegel nicht weiter
vom Finanzminister von der FDP über den
Tisch ziehen lassen ein guter Plan wäre
dass der Haushaltsausschuss jetzt die
Arbeit macht bis zur zweiten Lesung 78
Euro für jedes Kind das wäre doch ein
gutes Ziel meine lieben
stellen sich einmal drei Minuten lang
vor aus dem Sondervermögen Aufrüstung
wird ein Sondervermögen von 100
Milliarden Euro gegen Kinderarmut dann
wären natürlich diese 78 Euro überhaupt
kein Problem beim Kampf gegen die
Kinderarmut müssen sie deutlich
nachlegen da haben Sie unsere volle
Unterstützung Frau Ministerin
der Haushaltsausschuss bei der Haushalt
für ihr Ministerium umfasst nach dem
Plan 12,6 Milliarden Euro
für die Atombomber F35 sollen 15
Milliarden Euro ausgegeben werden mehr
als für Familien Senioren Frauen und
Jugend zusammen in einem Jahr und ich
glaube dieses Geld diese 15 Milliarden
Euro wären viel besser in einem
Ministerium angelegt dass sich für
Familien für Jugend für Frauen einsetzt
diese Änderung muss unbedingt erfolgen
meine Damen und Herren
und wenn schon das Grundgesetz geändert
werden soll dann kann ich alle nur
auffordern endlich eine 30 Jahre alte
Forderung ins Grundgesetz zu schreiben
nämlich Kinderrechte ins Grundgesetz
vielen Dank
hier sehen wir Lötsch war das für die
linker die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende
und jetzt hören wir für die Grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen lieber eine Spiegel Frau
breher dass sie hier tendenziell von
einer dreiwöchigen Auszeit oder
Abwesenheit der Ministerin sprechen dass
sie diese Debatte instrumentalisieren
für diesen Popanz obwohl sie wissen dass
die Ministerin drei Wochen an Corona
erkrankt ist dass die long coved hat wie
Millionen Menschen in diesem Land das
ist an Respektlosigkeit und
Schamlosigkeit nicht zu überbieten Frau
preher wer wäre ich in ihrer Fraktion
ich würde mich schämen für diese
Schamlosigkeit schämen sie sich Frau
breher
liebe Anne Spiegel ich freue mich dass
Du hier wieder bei uns bist ich freue
mich dass wir gemeinsam jetzt für eine
konstruktive für eine ziel- und
lösungsorientierte Gesellschaft und
Familienpolitik kämpfen können ich freue
mich dass wir Schluss machen können mit
all den Altlasten die sie uns
hinterlassen haben das gehen wir an
liebe Anne spiegeln
liebe
Kolleginnen die Koalition hat sich im
Bereich der Gesellschaft und
Familienpolitik viel vorgenommen und
erste Maßnahmen bereits auf den Weg
gebracht der 219a wird aus dem
Strafgesetzbuch gestrichen die
Ministerin hat es auf den Weg gebracht
und das ist so überfällig endlich machen
wir Schluss mit diesem
gesellschaftspolitischen Unrecht
aber ich möchte noch mal Anknüpfen an
das was die Ministerin auch schon gesagt
hat die Menschen in der Ukraine gehen
aktuell durch die Hölle es ist ein Gebot
der Menschlichkeit zu helfen jetzt wo
die Not so groß ist im Angesicht der
russischen Aggression ich bin der
Ministerin dankbar dass sie sich diese
Aufgabe entschlossen stellt und viele
spezifische Hilfsangebote auf den Weg
bringt wie die zum Schutz
Alleinreisender Frauen die die zum
Schutz schwangerer oder von Waisenkinder
oder eben auch die Evakuierung von
Pflegebedürftigen Holocaust Überlebenden
das ist so wichtig liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Deutschland ist in der
Verantwortung Deutschland stellt sich
seiner Verantwortung wir helfen den
Menschen in der Not es ist wichtig dass
wir versuchen so schnell wie es
irgendwie geht ein Stück Normalität
zurückzugewinnen für die Schutzsuchenden
dass wir gemeinsam organisieren dass
insbesondere die Kinder
alle Schulen und Kitas gehen können für
uns alle für die Kommunen und für die
Länder für den Bund ist es jetzt eine
große Kraftanstrengung und die wir
gemeinsam vollbringen werden dabei
ändert sich die Lage so dynamisch dass
sich es für richtig finde das ist die
richtige Entscheidung ist dass die
Bundesregierung hier ein
ergänzungshaushalt auflegt der ein Teil
dieser Kraftanstrengung abbilden wird
und gerade
und gerade vor dem Hintergrund der
Familien- und Kinder die zu uns kommen
ist der Kita und ganztagsausbau so
wichtig und ich werbe dafür dass wir ein
Sofortprogramm in den ergänzungshaushalt
aufnehmen
der bereits vorliegende Entwurf für den
Altar des bmffj weiß mit 12,58
Milliarden Euro zusätzliche 147
Millionen im Vergleich zum ersten
Regierungsentwurf der Vorgängerregierung
auf das sind 147 Millionen Euro
zusätzlich für Familien für die Jugend
für die Gleichberechtigung dieses Geld
ist gut angelegt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
der mit 86 Prozent größte Teil des etas
ist für die gesetzlichen Leistung
vorgesehen allen voran dass Elterngeld
dieses Instrument wird gut angenommen
und das trägt maßgeblich zur
Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf bei
aber wir werden es noch besser machen
indem wir es vereinfachen indem wir es
digitalisieren und indem wir die
gemeinschaftliche elterliche
Verantwortung stärken
und auch im Programmbereich ist diese
Regierungsentwurf ein guter erster
Aufschlag für das parlamentarische
Verfahren da möchte ich insbesondere auf
die Erhöhung des Ansatzes für das
Programm aufholen nach Corona für Kinder
und Jugendliche verweisen das deutlich
aufgestockt wurde auf 272 Millionen Euro
gerade nach Corona brauchen Kinder
Jugendliche und Familien weiterhin
unsere Unterstützung und diese
Unterstützung bekommen sie von dieser
Bundesregierung
das BMFSFJ unter Anne Spiegel steht für
unsere lebendige Demokratie für Vielfalt
und für eine moderne Gesellschaft
deswegen ist es gut dass wir den Ansatz
für die demokratie-förderung und
extremismusprävention auf 184 Millionen
Euro aufstocken dass wir das
Erfolgsprogramm Demokratie leben um 15
Millionen ausbauen und dass das
Patenschaftsprogramm Menschen stärken
Menschen um 18 Millionen verstärkt wird
all das sind Investitionen die unsere
Demokratie noch wehrhafter machen die
früh ansetzen und damit besonders
wirkungsvoll sind angesichts der
multiple Herausforderung vor denen wir
stehen muss sich anmerken dass ich mich
sehr gefreut habe über das klare
Bekenntnis von Finanzminister Christian
Lindner zur Kindergrundsicherung am
Dienstag dieser Woche mit der
Kindergrundsicherung werden wir
Kinderarmut bekämpfen eines der Probleme
unserer Zeit denn wir alle wissen dass
sich Armut reproduziert dass das
aufstiegsversprechen oft nicht mehr als
eine fl dafür ist deswegen ist die
Kinder Grundsicherung ein so wichtiges
Projekt dieser Ampelkoalition wir wollen
Chancengerechtigkeit für unsere
Kleinsten und nicht weniger als das
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und lassen Sie mich abschließend
bemerken dass natürlich nicht alle
unsere gesellschaftspolitischen Vorhaben
jetzt schon it harreif sind aber das
schmälert nicht ihre Bedeutsamkeit und
auch nicht unsere Entschlossenheit den
Koalitionsvertrag in diesem Bereich
vollumfänglich umzusetzen anführen will
ich neben der Kindergrundsicherung auch
dass die Familienpflegezeit oder die
frauenhausfinanzierung um nur einige der
wichtigen Projekte in der Zuständigkeit
der Ministerin anzuführen das sind
dringend nötige Vorhaben für die Chancen
und Generationengerechtigkeit wir werden
Sie gemeinsam umsetzen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen herzlichen Dank
Bruno höhnel war das für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen hier zum
familienetat
das Elterngeld hat er noch mal besonders
hervorgehoben ah ja in ganz großer Teil
dieses Etats der ins Elterngeld fließt
7,73
Milliarden Euro für die Union jetzt hier
nächster Redner Giro St Johann mit jedem
Ausschuss für Familie Senioren Frauen
und Jugend sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich weiß
nicht was ich da verbrochen habe dass
man meine zweite Silbe immer betont ich
glaube das kommt aus dem russischen also
die Betonung ist Stoa Johann insofern
gebe ich das mal zu Protokoll
Johann sie haben gesagt meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren der Haushalts
das Haushalts der Entwurfe das
Haushaltsgesetz 422 liegt auf dem Tisch
er spiegelt aber nicht im Ansatz die
angekündigten familienpolitischen
Vorhaben der Ampelkoalition wieder der
Kollege Hönel hat das eben ja auch
entsprechend ausgeführt aber auch der
Entwurf des Gesamthaushalts ist
insgesamt unsolide
ein Nachtragshaushalt ist bereits in
Planung Sondervermögen neben Haushalte
und eine deutliche Erhöhung der
Verschuldung das ist nicht nachhaltig
und der Entchen nämlich noch an viele
Reden von Christian Lindner hier der das
natürlich auch alles früher gegeistert
hat das ist Generation ungerecht diese
enorme Verschuldung
der Einzelplan 17 beläuft sich nur noch
auf 12,6 Milliarden Euro das ist eine
etwas geringere Summe als zehn Jahren
zuvor das macht drei Prozent des
kernhaushaltes und der Großteil dieses
Haushaltes das sind gesetzliche
Leistungen für Familien das Elterngeld
oder der Kinderzuschlag und ja auch in
manchen Titeln steigen die Ansätze um
kleine Beträge aber was macht denn die
Regierung überhaupt
in der Familienpolitik wo setzt sie
Schwerpunkte wo werden
familienpolitische neue Entscheidungen
getroffen es gehört ja zur Wahrheit dass
viele familienpolitische Schwerpunkte
nicht in ihrem ressortraum Ministerin
Spiegel entschieden werden
beispielsweise die Einführung einer
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft die
Abschaffung des Paragrafen 219a oder
auch das steuerliche Kindergeld denn
Familienpolitik ist immer auch
Bildungspolitik Rechtspolitik Steuer und
Finanzpolitik sie schlagen daher auch
nicht finanziell bei uns im Haushalt zu
buchen das heißt im Endeffekt dass die
Entscheidung darüber wie Familien leben
wahrgenommen und unterstützt werden
immer weniger in ihrem Ressort getroffen
werden Frau Ministerin das ist das in
ihrem Sinne müssen sie das nicht ändern
das Ministerium trägt den Namen
Bundesministerium für Familie Senioren
Frauen und Jugend Familien stehen nicht
nur ganz vorne sie sollten das auch zu
repräsentieren denn ohne Familie ist
kein Staat zu machen so kann ein Staat
nicht funktionieren wenn die Familie
nicht funktionieren doch was brauchen
Familie
und welche Familien wollen wir mit
unserer Politik insgesamt unterstützen
wie soll Familienpolitik zielgenau und
effektiv sein Familie wenn sie letzten
Endes unbestimmt ist und nahezu beliebig
wird was heißt das dann ist es nur noch
ein Aspekt der Sozialpolitik wir als
Union wollen dass es den Familien gut
geht allen Familien alle Mitgliedern
einer Familie wir wissen dass die
Familien oft erheblichen Belastung
ausgesetzt sind gerade jetzt vor dem
Hintergrund steigender Preise und der
Krise und dem Krieg in der Ukraine
unsere Aufgabe als Politiker muss es
deshalb sein die richtigen
Rahmenbedingungen zu stellen
Wahlfreiheit zu ermöglichen und Mut zu
machen sich für Familie für
Verbindlichkeit und für auch für Kinder
zu entscheiden aber ohne Ideologie und
ohne Bevormundung die Aufgabe des
Staates ist der besondere Schutz von Ehe
und Familie so jedenfalls unsere
Auffassung und auch Ihre Unterstützung
der Staat hilft den Eltern ihre
Verantwortung für Kinder zu übernehmen
und auch sich das Kinder sich auch um
ihre Eltern kümmern der Staat er kann
nicht lieben er gehört nicht an den
Küchentisch aber er kümmert sich im
eigenen Interesse ersetzt die
Rahmenbedingungen für Infrastruktur für
Zeit und für Geld wenn Sie planen
insbesondere wirtschaftlich schwächere
Familien mehr zu unterstützen dann
findet das selbstverständlich unsere
Zustimmung aber in den
Haushaltsberatungen hier findet sich
davon nichts und was ist mit allen
anderen Familien und ihren Kindern wie
stehen sie zur Höhe des Kindergeldes und
der Kinderfreibeträge wir fordern daher
eine Überprüfung und Anpassung der
Besteuerung und der
Versicherungsbeiträge von Familien
Familien brauchen auch eine
Infrastruktur fest steht dass immer
weniger Familien sich für drei oder mehr
Kinder entscheiden warum sind Kinder bei
uns nicht wirklich willkommen sind sie
eine Last ein Armutsrisiko ein Grund für
Einschränkung Kinder sind ein Geschenk
und Familien mit Kindern ein Gewinn für
die Gesellschaft ist die unterstützende
Infrastruktur dafür unzureichend wir
haben als Union in der letzten
Legislaturperiode beispielsweise in der
Ganztagsbetreuung für Grundschulkinder
einen guten Grundstein mit der SPD
zusammengelegt jetzt heißt es aber
weiterhin mit zusätzlichen Finanzhilfen
den Kommunen dabei Hilfestellung zu
geben
Betreuungsangebote zu schaffen und aus
Kitas gute Kinder zu machen
Familien brauchen aber auch eins und das
ist Zeit eine flexiblere Zeiteinteilung
für beide Elternteile das fängt bei
familienfreundlichen Arbeitszeiten an
das geht über Modelle beim Elterngeld
Homeoffice Möglichkeiten und behört bei
der Förderung von haushaltsnahen
Dienstleistungen nicht auf von einer
Neugestaltung beim Elterngeld oder nur
einer ernsthaften Ausweitung der
Partnermonate fehlt auch in diesem
Haushalt jedes Spur liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wie Sie sehen ist nicht nur
die Liste der Versprechen in den
Wahlprogrammen von dem koalitionsverein
und dem Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel lang
auch die Berechtigten Wünsche und
Bedürfnisse der Familien sind zahlreich
die cdu/csu-fraktion erwartet dass sie
noch erheblich Nacharbeiten so wie sie
das hier angekündigt haben denn ihr
Haushaltsentwurf ist nicht optimal
[Applaus]
und es folgt für die SPD-Fraktion die
Kollegin Josefine Ortlepp
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe Anne
Spiegel sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es fühlt sich toll an nach
längerer Zeit wieder hier zu sein nach
der Geburt meines Sohnes haben mich
unendlich viele Glückwünsche erreicht
und ich möchte die Chance nutzen an
dieser Stelle auch danke dafür zu sagen
gemeinsam mit meinem Sohn der
hoffentlich in meinem Büro gerade gut
schläft lerne ich den parlamentsalltag
noch mal mit ganz anderen Augen kennen
für mich ist das hier relativ gut zu
vereinbaren und zu organisieren viel
besser als für Millionen von Frauen die
sich fragen wie Sie Arbeit Familie und
einfach das Leben unter einen Hut
bekommen sollen umso verletzender muss
es für diese Millionen von Frauen sein
wenn Sie hier im Hause immer wieder und
wir haben es auf besonders widerliche
Art heute schon gehört behauptet wird
das mit der Gleichberechtigung sei doch
längst schon erreicht wir bräuchten
keine Kampagnen keine Quoten keine
Frauenförderung mehr wir seien doch alle
gleich so die Theorie nur liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen was nützt uns
Frauen die Theorie wenn wir in der
Praxis auf so viele Hürden stoßen
theoretisch können wir Frauen
Führungspositionen übernehmen aber
praktisch kriegt die Beförderung dann
doch der männliche Kollege theoretisch
wollen wir uns politisch engagieren aber
praktisch sind Abendtermine mit Kindern
kaum machbar theoretisch sollte es
keinen Unterschied machen welches
Geschlecht man hat wie man aussieht oder
wenn man liebt aber praktisch macht es
eben doch ein Unterschied es reicht uns
nicht theoretisch gleichberechtigt zu
sein wenn am Ende unser Kontostand
geringer ist und unsere Renten kleiner
sind
deswegen brauchen wir einen Haushalt der
Frauen in Deutschland stärkt einen
Haushalt der Hürden abbaut und ein
Haushalt der alle sieht ein Beispiel
sind für mich dafür vor allen Dingen
auch die Mittel des die für die
Antidiskriminierungsstelle des Bundes
eingestellt sind die mit ihrer Arbeit
wirklich Menschen Mut macht sich gegen
Diskriminierung zu wehren diese Arbeit
sollten wir künftig finanziell stärker
stellen
ganz besonders freut mich außerdem dass
wir die Bundesstiftung für
Gleichstellung wachsen lassen ich glaube
da geht auch noch mehr aus meiner Sicht
und auch die vielen Frauenverbände und
Frauenorganisationen müssen wir
unterstützen denn ihre Expertise für
gleichstellungs für gute
Gleichstellungspolitik ist von
unschätzbarem Wert
und trotz der aktuellen Herausforderung
werden wir die finanziellen Mittel die
wir noch in der letzten Vorhabenplanung
angestoßen haben werden diese Mittel so
jetzt auch kommen denn auch in
Krisenzeiten dürfen mutige große
Schritte in Richtung einer gerechteren
Zukunft nicht fehlen
deswegen ist der Einzelplan 17 so
wichtig und ich freue mich auf die
Beratung mit den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und vor allen Dingen auf die
Zusammenarbeit mit meiner Kollegin
Elisabeth Kaiser denn klar ist was jetzt
nicht passieren darf ein Rückwärtssalto
in alte Rollenmuster unsere Aufgabe als
parlamentarier:innen ist es deshalb
Frauen zu stärken und ihnen zu zeigen
wir sehen euch wir sehen eure Leistung
wir sehen eure Erschöpfung und wir
greifen euch unter die Arme wir kümmern
uns darum dass ihr nicht an den Herd
gedrängt werdet wenn ihr das gar nicht
wollt wir schaffen die rechtlichen
Rahmenbedingungen damit aus der Theorie
endlich Praxis wird wir geben euch die
Sicherheit um über euer Leben selbst zu
bestimmen
politisch heißt das für uns als
SPD-Fraktion wir müssen Gleichstellung
in allen gesetzgebungsbereichen denken
deswegen freue ich mich auf den
gleichstellungs-check und dass wir die
ressortübergreifende Gleichstellung
Strategie weiterführen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen mit diesem Haushaltsentwurf
haben wir die Chance politisch endlich
dahin zu kommen wo die Gesellschaft
längst ist und die konservativen
Parteien das haben wir in der letzten
Legislaturperiode echt erlebt hier im
Haus leider nie waren die Botschaft die
am Ende von diesem Haushalt ausgehen
muss an Frauen in Deutschland ist jetzt
erst recht wir kämpfen für euch und wir
kämpfen für den Fortschritt vielen Dank
Josefine Ortlieb war das für die
SPD-Fraktion wie sie Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Familie Senioren Frauen
und Jugend
Ulrike Schielke Ziesing
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin meine Damen und
Herren eigentlich gehört die Familie die
Kernzelle unserer Gesellschaft an die
erste Stelle ich sage eigentlich denn
wenn man sich anschaut wie ihr Haushalt
aufgestellt ist kann man sagen dass sie
und ihre Regierung die Wertschätzung der
Familien in Deutschland nicht zu hoch
ansetzen eher im Gegenteil ein Minus von
630 Millionen Euro gegenüber 2021 das
sind die nackten Zahlen ein Minus von
630 Millionen in Zeiten wo viele
Familien die von ihnen verursachten
Kostenexplosionen ausbaden müssen ich
spreche von Benzinpreisen die jenseits
aller Vorstellungen liegen von der
Kostenexplosion bei Strom und Heizung
ein Durchschnittshaushalt kann dieses
Jahr mit einer Preissteigerung von 2000
Euro rechnen und das alles ist erst der
Anfang es wird noch schlimmer das ist
das Resultat ihrer Politik die Politik
der Altparteien der letzten Jahre
der vorgeschlagene Haushalt liest sich
wie ein schlechter Scherz für die
Familien statt die Familien für die
bereits bestehende und auf uns
zukommende Krise zu wappnen und
finanziell zu entlasten werden völlig
falsche Anreize gesetzt auf der einen
Seite einen einseitig gibt es nämlich
den Geldsegen den millionenfachen
Geldsegen für Maßnahmen zu Stärkung von
Vielfalt Toleranz und Demokratie klingt
alles auf dem Papier schön mehr
Demokratie fördern toll dahinter
verstecken sich dann aber vielfach
fragwürdige Organisationen wie die
Antonio Amadeus Stiftung deren
Vorsitzende eine ehemalige inoffizielle
stasi-mitarbeiterin war für solche
Organisationen sind immerhin 183
Millionen Euro vorgesehen ein Plus von
satten 33 Millionen gegenüber den
Vorjahr und das mitten in der Krise so
was muss man sich leisten wollen wir von
der AFD sagen hier ganz klar nein
wenn sie sparen wollen dann wäre es
angebracht beispielsweise unserem Antrag
zu folgen um das Kindergeld vom Ausland
lebende Kinder endlich zu indexieren so
etwas kann noch nicht sein dass ein Kind
das in Rumänien oder Polen aufwächst mit
dem gleichen Kindergeld ausgestattet
wird wie einst das in München lebt das
meine Damen und Herren ist ungerecht das
Kindergeld soll nicht das Einkommen
ersetzen bzw
einen Anreiz für sozialtourismus
darstellen das erkannte bereits der alte
Chef der spd-sigmar Gabriel 2016 also
kurz vor seinem politischen aus und
forderte genau das was wir als AFD schon
länger fordern und so macht es übrigens
auch Österreich vor kürzen Sie
stattdessen richtig bei den schwächsten
der Schwachen bei den Beiträgen zu den
Jugendwerken da zum Teil mehr als um die
Hälfte auch bei der Fachkräfte Offensive
ebenso um 50 Millionen gekürzt bzw das
Programm läuft jetzt aus haben wir etwa
kein Fachkräftemangel mehr hat die
Offensive denn ihre Ziele erreicht eher
nicht wenn man sich die Arbeits Anlage
anschaut wieder wurde Geld verbrannt für
nichts und wo wir beim Geld verbrennen
sind müssen wir auch über den
Unterhaltsvorschuss sprechen an sich da
sind wir uns hoffentlich alle einig eine
wichtige Aufgabe des Sozialstaates
Kinder sollen nicht auf ihre Unterhalts
ihren Unterhaltsansprüchen sitzen
bleiben nur bei den Elternteil sich
weigert zu zahlen nur der Staat sollte
dann aber auch dieses Geld von diesen
Eltern Wiederholen der
Bundesrechnungshof und da auch der
Rechnungsprüfungsausschuss haben hier in
das Ministerium schon mehrmals angemahnt
und ich sehe immer noch keine
Fortschritte eine Milliarde Euro wird
ausgegeben eingetrieben werden lediglich
150 Millionen bzw 15 Prozent der Bund
macht hier also 850 Millionen Euro - im
Jahr Geld das anderswo fehlt das kann
doch nicht sein
ich fasse zusammen ihre Politik ist dass
die dazu beiträgt dass ich immer weniger
Menschen für eine Familiengründung
entscheiden statt eine Politik zu machen
die die Familien entlastet legen Sie
diesen noch zusätzlich Steine in den Weg
freuen dürfen sich lediglich ihre
Parteikollegen so ein Haushalt können
wir als AFD nicht mittragen wir werden
in den Haushaltsberatungen sehen ob sie
offen für sinnvolle Vorschläge sind ich
bedanke mich
[Applaus]
und das Wort erhält für die FDP-Fraktion
der Kollege Matthias Seestern pauli
er ist der familienpolitische Sprecher
der Liberalen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Ministerin meine sehr geehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zu oft wurden
in der Vergangenheit die Interessen von
Familien Kindern und Jugendlichen
zurückgestellt und die corona-pandemie
hat die Situation für viele noch einmal
deutlich verschärft hinzu kommt nun die
wirklich dramatische Situation der
ukrainischen Familien und Kinder die vor
dem russischen Angriffskrieg fliehen wir
müssen die Schutzsuchenden
schnellstmöglich versorgen und
integrieren und die Kinder in unsere
Schulen und Kitas aufnehmen und ja das
stellt den Bund und auch die Länder vor
allem aber unsere Fachkräfte in den
Einrichtungen den ich an dieser Stelle
von Herzen Dank sagen möchte vor riesige
Herausforderungen
wir alle wir alle wissen dass die
Schulen und die Kitas schon in der
corona-pandemie stark belastet wurden
und es nun zusätzlich werden meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren es ist deshalb
auch richtig dass wir mit dem von der
Ampelkoalition eingebrachten Haushalt
erste neue Schwerpunkte für die Zukunft
setzen und dazu gehört natürlich auch
dass dieser Haushalt den wir nun
vorliegen knapp einer halbe Milliarde
über dem liegt lieber Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Union den sie noch mit
eingebracht haben und das zieht sich in
der mittelfristigen Finanzplanung sofort
das vielleicht mal zur Erinnerung und
damit und dem angekündigten
ergänzungshaushalt zeigen wir
dass sich in der Familienpolitik nun
etwas ändern wird und wir auch in neuen
krisenhandlungsfähig sind lassen sie
mich deshalb kurz auf einige wenige
Aspekte eingehen erstens ich begrüße es
sehr dass die Mittel für den Kinder- und
jugendplan steigen und auch die frühen
Hilfen weiter gestärkt werden
zweitens
Stichwort sprachkitas auch hier werden
die Mittel deutlich erhöht und das ist
auch richtig so denn Sprache ist der
Schlüssel zur Integration und Teilhabe
drittens Stichwort Engagement und
Ehrenamt wir alle wissen wie wichtig
Ehrenamt für unsere Gesellschaft ist
deshalb werden wir mit diesem Haushalt
Programme fördern die sich hierauf
konzentrieren gerade in der aktuellen
Zeit werbe ich für das Programm Menschen
stärken Menschen dass sich bewährt und
den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
gestärkt hat deshalb ist es auch richtig
dass wir dieses Programm nun mit
zusätzlichen Mitteln ausstatten 4
Stichwort Elterngeld auch hier gibt es
eine weiterhin positive Entwicklung
jedoch haben wir uns im
Koalitionsvertrag unter anderem bei den
partnermonaten noch mehr vorgenommen
auch muss das Elterngeld weiter
vereinfacht und digitalisiert werden
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren sie
sehen bereits nach kurzer Zeit machen
wir viele Schritte in die richtige
Richtung aber klar ist auch dass wir
gerade erst am Anfang und noch lange
nicht am Ziel sind
abschließend das ist mir ein
persönliches Anliegen auch nach dieser
Debatte möchte ich noch zwei Sätze sagen
auch wirklich kurz ich muss sagen ich
bin jetzt seit vier Jahren im Bereich
fsfj unterwegs das Herr Reichardt mit
seiner Polemik die Debatte regelmäßig
nach unten zieht das ist nichts Neues
wir sollten aber und das bitte ich jetzt
wirklich als Appell aufzustehen und
darüber Gedanken machen jeder der sich
angesprochen fühlt ob es richtig ist
wirklich mit billigen Angriffen das
Niveau so zur auszurollen wir selber ich
habe mit ihnen rede ich gerade gar nicht
erreicht hat sondern es geht uns im
Endeffekt hier um die Familien um die
Kinder und um die Jugendlichen und das
sollte unser Schwerpunkt sein herzlichen
Dank
[Musik]
also jeder mag hier um hohes Niveau
Ringen da sind wir sehr dafür und dass
die nächste Chance bekommt Heidi
Reicheneck für die Linke
die frauenpolitische Sprecherin der
Linken
ja das ist doch ein guter Start sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Ministerin ich habe
jetzt in den letzten sechs Jahren mit
Kindern und Jugendlichen gearbeitet die
nicht auf der Sonnenseite des Lebens
stehen und deswegen bin ich schockiert
dass der vorliegende Haushalt als
einzige Neuerung ein mangelhaften Kinder
sofortzuschlag bietet für den sich die
Kolleginnen der Ampel dafür aber umso
kräftiger auf die Schulter klopfen den
Kindern sofort Zuschlag bekommen 2,9
Millionen Kinder im Leistungsbezug
prinzipiell eine gute Sache aber der
Zuschlag kommt weder sofort sondern erst
im Juli noch wird er den im
Gesetzentwurf genannten zielgerecht ich
zitiere dazu beizutragen die
Lebensumstände und Chancen der Kinder zu
verbessern wie auch bei einer Höhe von
20 Euro das gleicht doch nicht mal die
aktuellen Preissteigerung und
coronabedingten Mehrbedarfe aus von der
grundlegenden Problematik der
Kinderarmut ganz zu schweigen 20 Euro
wie kommt man auf diesen Betrag zuerst
hört man ja aus dem grünen
Familienministerium lächerliche 25 Euro
dann dachte sicher schlimmer kann es ja
nicht mehr werden und dann kam das
SPD-geführte Arbeitsministerium und
konterte mit erbärmlichen 10 Euro das
haben Sie vielleicht vergessen aber ich
lasse sie nicht vergessen ist das der
Respekt den sie auf die Wahlplakate
gekleistert haben
jetzt sind wir bei 20 Euro liebe
Kolleginnen die Sozialverbände hatten
für einen wirksamen sofortzuschlag eine
Zahlung von mindestens 78 Euro gefordert
wurde das überhaupt diskutiert wurden
die Bedürfnisse von Kindern und
Jugendlichen und Familien berücksichtigt
oder nur in vorauseilendem Gehorsam die
der FDP zwar werden mal eben über Nacht
100 Milliarden für Aufrüstung aus dem
Boden gestampft für den Kinder
sofortzuschlag gibt es aber nur rund 380
Millionen nicht mal 0,4 Prozent des
Sondervermögens das ist für Rheinmetall
gibt liebe Kolleginnen dieser
sofortzuschlag ist respektlos mehr noch
ich ahne was das für die Höhe einer
zukünftigen Kindergrundsicherung
bedeutet Bürokratieabbau das traue ich
der fdp-regierung durchaus zu aber um
Kinder aus der Armut zu holen braucht es
schlicht und ergreifend mehr Geld für
gesundes Essen für warme Kleidung für
Teilhabe und wo wäre das Geld besser
angelegt als bei unseren Kindern Frau
Ministerin ich freue mich dass sie
wieder gesund sind und ich weiß auch sie
wollen einen höheren Kinder so
vorzuschlag auch sie wollen eine
Kindergrundsicherung die den Namen
verdient hat also setzen Sie sich in der
Regierung dafür ein sie haben uns an
ihrer Seite
gesagt Heidi Reicheneck ganz klar hier
für die Linksfraktion ja der Kinder
sofort Zuschlag schon mehrfach hier
Thema soll ja monatlich 20 Euro betragen
ab dem 1 Juli ausgezahlt werden so lange
bis irgendwann die Kinder Grundsicherung
eingeführt wird auf die sicher SPD grün
und FDP im Koalitionsvertrag verständigt
hatten
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
seit dem 24 Februar 2022 ist unsere Welt
eine andere
wir haben in den letzten Wochen hier in
diesem Haus zu recht viel über
Waffenlieferungen und Sanktionen
gesprochen jetzt müssen wir bei Familien
und Kinder sprechen die zu uns fliehen
wir müssen die Kindern aus der Ukraine
schnell einen Platz in unseren
Kindertagesstätten bieten und wir müssen
die Ehrenamtlichen unterstützen die mit
so viel Kraft helfen egal ob am Berliner
Hauptbahnhof oder in Ueckermünde
was müssen wir dafür tun
erstens wir brauchen Sofortmaßnahmen für
unsere Kindertagesstätten wer die
Familien aus der Ukraine eine
Perspektive geben will muss jetzt die
Kitas vorbereiten und für ausreichend
kita-personal sorgen wir benötigen einen
ersten Schritt niedrigschwellige
Angebote um die Kinder an die Kitas
heranzuführen dafür können wir
erfolgreiche Programme wie kita-einstieg
und griffbereit nutzen als zweiten
Schritt werden wir die Kinder die
übrigens ein Rechtsanspruch auf ein
Kitaplatz haben in unseren Kitas
aufnehmen hierfür müssen wir mehr
Personal bereitstellen wir müssen
schnell handeln
schnelle Anerkennung ukrainische
Abschlüsse für Erzieherinnen zusätzliche
Mittel damit angehende Erzieherinnen in
den Kitas unterstützen können
zusätzliche Plätze für den
Freiwilligendienst in Kindertagesstätten
eine Verantwortungsgemeinschaft
Personalgewinnung aus bund-
und wir brauchen endlich die
schulgeldfreiheit in ganz Deutschland
niemand im Land kann verstehen dass
gerade in der jetzigen Situation immer
noch junge Menschen Geld dafür zahlen
müssen damit sie Erzieherin werden
können
zweitens wir müssen die Ehrenamtlichen
in Deutschland unterstützen wir sehen
seit Wochen wie ehrenamtliche
Helferinnen und Helfer unglaublich für
die ankommende geflüchteten leisten
unzählige Initiativen Vereinen helfen
ganz praktisch Stellen Wohnraum zur
Verfügung und spenden
ich möchte mich dafür auch im Namen der
SPD-Fraktion ganz herzlich bei Ihnen
bedanken
die ehrenamtliche in Deutschland sind
das Rückgrat unser Zivilgesellschaft die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wollen aktiv sein
sie wollen helfen unsere Aufgabe ist als
Bund ist es dafür zu sorgen dass sie bei
diesem Engagement nicht alleine gelassen
werden für viele Vereine und Initiativen
ist die Deutsche Stiftung für Engagement
und Ehrenamt ein wichtiger Partner der
Staat der
stiftungsstiftungsarbeit während der
corona-pandemie war alles andere als
einfach alleine 2020 wurden über
12.500 Anträge bearbeitet die Vereine
haben das Achtfache des Budgets von 20
Millionen Euro beantragt das Achtfache
es ist eindeutig der Bedarf ist
wesentlich höher als das Budget der
Stiftung deswegen stellen wir 10
Millionen Euro mehr zur Verfügung
für mich steht fest die Stiftung ist
unser wichtigstes Instrument um das
Ehrenamt in Deutschland schnell und
bürokratisch zu unterstützen lassen Sie
uns deshalb gemeinsam in den nächsten
Wochen prüfen welche zusätzlichen
Aufgaben die Stiftung für die
Unterstützung der Ehrenamtlichen Hilfe
für Familien aus der Ukraine übernehmen
kann
liebe Frau Ministerin Spiegel in dieser
schwierigen Situation arbeiten sie daran
dass schwierige Situationen arbeiten sie
daran dass er unterstützen und gut
vorzubereiten in diesen
Haushaltsverhandlungen übernehmen wir
gemeinsam mit Ihnen als Abgeordnete
Verantwortung ich verspreche Ihnen und
ich verspreche allen Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern wir werden in den nächsten
Wochen alles dafür tun damit die zu uns
fliehenden Familien gut und sicher bei
uns ankommen danke schön
sagt Eric von Malotki von der SPD und
erhält dafür
Beifall vor allem natürlich aus seiner
Fraktion jetzt hören wir mal wie es
weitergeht hier
zum Einzelplan ja der letzte ich darf
schon mal darauf hinweisen dass wir in
ungefähr einer guten halben Stunde ja
hier noch die Schlussrunde zum
Haushaltsgesetz haben noch mal mit
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner unter
anderem aber jetzt am Rednerpult erstmal
Anne Jansen für die Union liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor genau zwei
Jahren beschloss der Deutsche Bundestag
umfangreiche Hilfspakete um die
negativen Folgen der corona-pandemie
abzumildern eine einzigartige
Neuverschuldung von 156 Milliarden Euro
sie applaudierten hier im Hohen Hause
den Heldinnen und Helden des Alltags die
das Leben im ersten Lockdown mit ihrer
systemrelevanten Arbeit aufrecht
erhielten aber wo stehen wir heute nach
zwei Jahren in der Pandemie als Lehrerin
sehe ich Kinder mit großen
lernrückständen als Mutter sehe ich
Familien die auch heute noch mit dem
Belastungen durch Quarantäne und dem
eigenen Beruf am Limit sind und als
Tochter sehe ich Seniorinnen und
Senioren zum Teil noch immer isoliert
leben und als Krankenschwester sehe ich
pflegende die sich immer noch für ihre
Patienten aufopfern heute genau zwei
Jahre später liegt uns der Einzelplan 17
des Bundeshaushaltes vor der bereits 147
Millionen Euro mehr enthält als noch der
erste Regierungsentwurf im letzten Jahr
das ist im gesamten zwar nur ein
winziger Zuwachs freut mich aber dennoch
sehr für jede einzelne Empfängerin und
jeden einzelnen Empfänger denn eines ist
sicher jeder der insgesamt 12,6
Milliarden Euro der zu Unterstützung
unserer Familien Seniorinnen und
Senioren Frauen und Jugendlichen
ausgegeben wird ist gut investiertes
Geld sicher
ist aber auch dass es zur Stärkung und
Förderung unserer Gesellschaft immer
mehr Mittel sein könnten lassen Sie uns
das Augenmerk also weniger auf die
zahlen und dafür mehr auf den Inhalt und
die geplanten Maßnahmen deren
Wirksamkeit lenken oder konkreter gesagt
lassen Sie uns auf den nicht-inhalt und
die fehlenden Maßnahmen und deren nötige
Wirksamkeit schauen denn eines fällt mir
besonders auf eine Zielgruppe und das
ist heute auch deutlich geworden wird
vom für Sie zuständigen Ressort häufig
nur der Vollständigkeit halber erwähnt
meine Damen und Herren die Seniorinnen
und Senioren was schwer nachvollziehbar
ist wenn wir bedenken dass diese
Menschen unsere Eltern unsere Großeltern
ehemalige Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer oder
Erzieherinnen und Erzieher sind Frauen
und Männer die uns geprägt haben die in
unser Land seinen heutigen Wohlstand
verdankt und die ich erwähnte es
eingangs wichtige soziale Strukturen
dauerhaft verloren haben Einsamkeit
ihrer Nebenwirkungen und der Umgang mit
ihr bestimmten in den letzten Jahren
zurecht die öffentliche Diskussion und
deswegen erklären Sie mir bitte und
allen Betroffenen warum dieses
gesellschaftlich bedeutende Problem zwar
in fast allen Regierungsprogramm
prominent mit einer Forderung nach einer
umfassenden Strategie zu finden war im
Koalitionsvertrag dann aber bis in die
Aufzählungen wegverhandelt wurde in
ihrem Einzelplan hilft dann auch die
Suchfunktion nicht weiter wie eigentlich
alle Vorhaben aus ihrer Wunschliste
namens mehr Fortschritt Wagen sucht man
die Umsetzung vergebens immerhin wollen
sie die Rolle der älteren Generation
stärken und deren wertvolles
Erfahrungswissen in die Gesellschaft
einbringen langfristig wollen sie und
unserer Gesellschaft sie zu einem
aktiven Leitbild einen Leitbild des
aktiven Alltags neu definieren eine sehr
lobenswerte Absicht konkrete Maßnahmen
zur Umsetzung suchte ich dann aber auf
den folgenden 113 Seiten des Einzelplan
17 erfolglos dabei benötigen gerade
langfristige vorhab willkommen zu einem
gesellschaftlichen Wandel viel Zeit die
sie nicht verlieren sollten also worauf
warten sie die Union war in den letzten
Legislaturen und insbesondere während
der corona-pandemie eine starke Stimme
der älteren Generation von unseren
umfangreichen Positionspapieren können
Sie sich bei Ihrer Arbeit sehr gern
inspirieren lassen
und auch die von uns initiierte
Förderung der mehrgeneration Häuser
legte schon vor Jahren den Grundstein
für ihren Wunsch nach einem neuen
Leitbild davon nach einem neuen Leitbild
und davon konnte ich mich in meinem
Wahlkreis bereits persönlich überzeugen
ein ebenso bedeutendes Element sozialer
Teilhabe aller Generation ist das seit
60 Jahren bewährte Erfolgsmodell des
Bundesfreiwilligendienstes er stärkt den
Zusammenhalt in der Gesellschaft
zwischen den Generationen und bereichert
das ganze weitere Leben der engagierten
Jugendlichen und selbstverständlich hat
die Union dieses Engagement als
unverzichtbare Investition in die
Zukunft der sozialen Berufe in der
letzten Legislatur als Schwerpunkt mit
65 Millionen Euro unterstützt mit großer
Sorge musste ich feststellen dass Sie
diesen Wert offenbar weniger bedeutend
einschätzen wie sonst erklären Sie die
faktische Kürzung der Fördermittel ab
Planungssicherheit ist für gewachsene
Strukturen wichtige Basis und
Grundvoraussetzung
wir können nur dann sinnvoll eingesetzt
werden wenn sie auch durch
Verpflichtungsermächtigung in den
Folgejahren abgesichert werden und wenn
die Verstetigung nicht jetzt
aufgegriffen wird ist es langfristig zu
spät ausgedünnte Strukturen sind bei
andauernden Fachkräftemangel kaum wieder
aufzubauen das Signal dass sie hier
setzen ist für die motivierten
Jugendlichen und die beteiligten
Einrichtungen eine schwere
Herabwürdigung
zu guter Letzt
ist es mir ein Herzensanliegen hier und
heute für die dauerhafte Förderung der
UN woman Deutschland zu werben als
Abgeordnete des Deutschen Bundestages
wurde mir die Ehre zuteil zur 66
un-frauenrechtskommission nach New York
zu reisen und vor Ort konnte ich mich
von der anspruchsvollen und
erfolgreichen Arbeit unserer deutschen
unwimmen überzeugen und ich möchte mich
an dieser Stelle sehr herzlich für die
ausgezeichnete inhaltliche
organisatorische und sehr persönliche
Begleitung bedanken bedauerlicherweise
beträgt der deutsche Beitrag an un woman
im zweiten Regierungsentwurf des BMZ 5
Millionen Euro weniger als 2021 und in
Anbetracht der aktuellen weltpolitischen
Lage und besonders im Hinblick auf die
vielen geflüchteten Frauen halte ich das
Engagement der Uhr in women für
wichtiger denn je und die geringe
Aufstockung des zuständigen Resorts für
ein völlig falsches Zeichen ich bitte
Sie also lieber ampelfraktion die
Entscheidung in den anstehenden
Beratungen zu korrigieren und die
derzeit unbeständige Projektförderung in
unserem Etat in einer auf Dauer
angelegte gesicherte Finanzierung zu
überführen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und es folgt für die FDP-Fraktion die
Kollegin Gide Jensen
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben den
Bezug zu Putins Angriffskrieg gegen die
freie souveräne europäische Ukraine in
dieser haushaltswoche oft gehört und ich
werde diesen Bezug auch herstellen denn
wenn wir über den Haushalt der bei
Tieren dann reden wir natürlich über
unsere politische To-Do-Liste für dieses
Jahr und auf dieser To-Do-Liste steht
für uns als Parlament die Verantwortung
alles in unserer Macht stehende dafür zu
tun um die Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer zu
unterstützen und zwar die die gerade mit
allem was sie haben ihr Land verteidigen
und die die von Putins Bomben in die
Flucht getrieben wurden und weiterhin
werden diese Bundesregierung hat sich
quer über alle Ressorts genau dieser
Verantwortung angenommen und hat sie
verstanden und dafür bedanke ich mich
ganz herzlich
und gleichzeitig hat die Koalition mit
dem Entlastungspaket gestern deutlich
gemacht wir tragen die Verantwortung
aber wir sehen auch wenn es Menschen
wenn das Familien in Deutschland an die
Belastungsgrenze bringt
rund 250.000 Ukrainerinnen sind
inzwischen in Deutschland angekommen
Frauen und viele viele Kinder und das
erfordert eine ganz besondere Form der
Schutzpflicht die unser Land hat das
muss und das wird sich in der Art der
Hilfen widerspiegeln die wir leisten und
zwar auch in der Unterbringung die
Ukrainerinnen die hier ankommen die sind
schockiert die sind verzweifelt sie sind
möglicherweise traumatisiert aber sie
sind nicht gebrochen sie sind stolz und
sie haben und sie werden ihre Heimat
nicht aufgeben und unser Job ist es
nicht sie zu bemüttern unser Job ist es
Ihnen zu ermöglichen ihren Beitrag zu
leisten den sie leisten möchten im
Bereich Kindergarten im Bereich
Kinderbetreuung als Lehrerin als
Betreuerin in den Schulen unser Job ist
es bereit zu stehen wenn Sie für sich
Unterstützung brauchen wenn Sie für Ihre
Kinder Unterstützung brauchen und so
sehen wir im Übrigen auch Familien Weg
so sehen wir Frauenpolitik ganz
grundsätzlich wir befähigen wir
bevormunden nicht wir stärken wir
betüdeln nicht
bei allen Ansätzen ist unser Credo dass
wir Programme die nicht funktionieren
einer ehrlichen Bestandsaufnahme
unterziehen und Programme bei denen wir
wissen dass sie funktionieren diese noch
besser machen und noch besser
ausgestatten
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Union die Regierungszeit ist jetzt ja
nur wenige Monate her ich kann mich noch
sehr gut an meine Oppositionszeit
erinnern und das Credo bei uns war immer
einen Haushaltstitel zu finden wo man
kürzen konnte um einen anderen zu
erhöhen bei der EURO Otto Fricke sagt es
in der Schlussrunde kann nur einmal
ausgegeben werden wenn sie hier in jeder
Debatte immer nur mehr mehr mehr fordern
wo ist dann ihr Anspruch an diese
ordentliche Haushaltspolitik die sie
auch immer eingefordert haben ich frage
mich das ganz ehrlich
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Koalition hat sich versprochen und wird
nicht zulassen dass diese Krisen eine
Pandemie oder auch ein abscheulicher
Krieg Lebenschancen zerstört Kinder und
Jugendliche egal wo sie herkommen wo sie
in Deutschland aufwachsen müssen
Lebensträume Träumen müssen Lebensträume
verwirklichen können und ich bin sehr
dankbar dass das auch unsere
Bundesfamilienministerin gemeinsam mit
unserer Bundesbildungsministerin in
diesem Anliegen an einer an einem Strang
zieht und ich bin sehr froh bedanke mich
an dieser Stelle für die starke Allianz
für echte Chancengerechtigkeit
herzlichen Dank
so weit die Rede der stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der FDP hier im
Deutschen Bundestag jede Jensen und auf
sie folgten und Felix Döring er ist
Mitglied der Sozialdemokraten und sitzt
im Familienausschuss des Bundestags
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren dieses Parlament wird
ja gern als die Herzkammer der
Demokratie bezeichnet aber ebenso wie
das menschliche Herz nicht dazu imstande
wäre einen Körper am Leben zu halten so
wäre es auch vermessen zu glauben dass
wir hier in diesem Hohen Hause die
einzigen sind die an unserer Demokratie
arbeiten denn das machen auch noch ganz
viele andere Menschen in diesem Land die
DGB Gewerkschaftsjugend beispielsweise
fährt regelmäßig raus an die
Berufsschulen in die Betriebe macht
wichtige Aufklärungsarbeit über
Mitbestimmung ermuntert dazu sich
einzubringen sich zu engagieren sich zu
organisieren und das auch mit Mitteln
die wir über den Kinder und jugendplan
zur Verfügung stellen meine Damen und
Herren und wo wir gerade beim Thema sind
noch bis Ende Mai finden Wahlen statt
für die Betriebsräte auch für die Jugend
auszubildendenvertretung und meine
herzliche Bitte an alle die hier gerade
zu die wählen können ist nehmen Sie
dieses Recht war setzen Sie ein Zeichen
für betriebliche Mitbestimmung über die
wir in den letzten Jahren schon manches
erreichen konnten und nehmen Sie an den
Wahlen teil
meine Damen und Herren unsere
Jugendverbände waren und sind von der
Pandemie stark gebeutelt sie leisten
trotzdem großartiges und es ist deswegen
richtig und wichtig dass wir die Mittel
im Kinder- und jugendplan auch über das
Corona aufholpaket massiv aufstocken und
ihnen so die nötigen Voraussetzungen zur
Verfügung stellen für ihre richtige und
wichtige Arbeit und dann haben wir noch
einen Posten demokratie-förderung
vorgesehen was verbirgt sich dahinter in
meinem Wahlkreis gibt es beispielsweise
eine sogenannte Partnerschaft für
Demokratie da haben Jugendliche eine
Satzung erarbeitet für eine Kinder- und
Jugendvertretung die haben sich
zusammengesetzt haben sich Gedanken
darüber gemacht was soll da rein haben
das ganze auch politisch durchgesetzt
und das hat jetzt den schönen Effekt
dass die Perspektive die Lebensrealität
von Kindern und Jugendlichen auf der
kommunalen Ebene Einfluss findet in die
Entscheidung die dort getroffen werden
meine Damen und Herren das ist gelebte
Demokratie und genauso heißt auch dieses
Programm Demokratie leben und das ist
und wichtig dass wir es entsprechend
aufstocken
ja ebenso wie das menschliche Herz für
die Durchblutung bis in die
Fingerspitzen bis in die Zehenspitzen
sorgt so sorgen wir mit dem vorliegenden
Haushalt für eine finanzielle
Durchblutung unserer demokratischen
Strukturen darauf können wir stolz sein
herzlichen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
wir kommen damit langsam zu den letzten
Rednern hier in der Debatte zum
Einzelplan 17 des Bundesministeriums für
Familien Senioren Frauen und jugenddritt
letzter Redner ist Paul Lerida aus der
Unionsfraktion
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen
werde geschätzte Frau Ministerin Spiegel
beim Blick auf die Regierungsbank muss
ich ein Kompliment aussprechen Frau
Ministerin Spiegel sie haben heute
morgen alles richtig gemacht beim Blick
in den Spiegel haben Sie sich für eine
Kleidung entschieden die der großen
Koalition entspricht das ist für eine
Familienminister absolut angemessen
meine
Damen und Herren schwarz rot
er müsste das müsste jetzt aushalten wir
Freunde von den Grünen von der FDP das
sehe ich ein Gemurmel bei den kleinen
Parteien
zu in kommen
die Füße stehen das Elterngeld 7,7
Milliarden Frau Ministerin Spiegel sie
haben es angesprochen wurde eingeführt
wer weiß es noch 2007 von einer
Ministerin von der Leyen also unter eine
CDU-Ministerin wurde das Elterngeld
angeführt eins der größten
Haushaltsposten bei uns jetzt im
Familienrecht da eines der größten
Erfolgsmodelle und sie Herr Kollege
höhnel haben selbst zugestehen müssen
dass es Elterngeld gut angenommen wird
gleichzeitig sprechen sie von Altlasten
der bisherigen Regierung ja Sie müssen
sich jetzt schon ein bisschen
entscheiden was tatsächlich stimmt und
was nicht stimmt sie können
sie können das mit dem Elterngeld nicht
wissen aber neben Ihnen sitzt die Frau
Hasselmann die ist damals mit mir in den
Bundestag eingezogen die hat das alles
mit
ihre Klamotten will ich heute nicht
reden kommt das nächste Mal wenn sie rot
wenn sie was schwarzes Drachenfrau
Hasselmann da können wir darüber
sprechen nein fragen Sie Ihre Kollegen
Hasselmann fragen Sie hier oben die
staatssekretäriges wie damals das
Elterngeld eingeführt wurde unter Uschi
von der Leyen wie gesagt und es war der
große Erfolg machen wenn ich jetzt auf
die Regierungsbank schaue muss ich noch
was fällt mir noch was auf ich sehe
direkt hinter der Ministerin gerade
unterhalten sie sich die
Staatssekretärin
Lehmann es ist ja tatsächlich so nach
dem aufgabenverteilungsplan in einem
Ministerium das bei Ausbau einer
Ministerin natürlich sehr tüchtige
Staatssekretäre und Staatssekretäre auch
mal die Aufgaben einer Minister
übernehmen können also
seit Jahren im Familienausschuss die
wird durchaus auch in der Lage die
vorhabensplanung des Ministeriums uns im
Ausschuss mal dazu legen wenn
tatsächlich Frau Ministerin wieder mal
was dazwischen kommen sollte gems ist
der Ecke davidos die kann das auch ihnen
wünsche ich natürlich alles gute zur
Genesung natürlich viel Gesundheit und
das nächste Coronavirus sich nicht
wieder back gut
zum Elterngeld noch erhöhen sie haben es
vorhin angesprochen das kann zu Ihrer
Information man kann ja bei einer
Plenardebatte immer auch noch was dazu
lernen das kann auch digital beantragt
werden mittlerweile möchte ich
ausdrücklich noch mal darauf hinweisen
der Haushalt des Familienministeriums
ist allein in den Jahren 2017 bis 2022
von 9,5 Milliarden auf 12,6 Milliarden
angewachsen das heißt in Zeiten der
großen Koalition wurde der Haushalt um
immerhin drei Milliarden über 3
Milliarden eben erhöht das war eine
erfolgszeit für Familien und ich bitte
die jetzige Koalition die Ampel
natürlich dieses Erfolgsmodell der
großen Koalition vernünftig fast zu
entwickeln wir werden sie dabei
selbstverständlich entsprechend
begleiten
der Einzelplan ist mit 12,6 Milliarden
ich habe darauf hingewiesen
natürlich eben schon hier eher ein
kleineren Frau Kollegin
launert hat vorhin für a&s ausgeführt
dass da der Haushalt 160 Milliarden
beträgt wir haben 12,6 Milliarden also
weniger als 10% des a&s Haushaltes
allerdings er ist natürlich der
gesellschaftlich wichtigste Haushalt
nach meinem Dafürhalten von diesen
angestrebten 12,6 Milliarden sind 86%
durch gesetzliche bzw vertragliche
Leistungen kaum disponieren nutzen Sie
bitte das bestehende Instrumentarium
Frau Ministerin und verbessern sie es wo
es sein müssen überblasen Sie bitte
nicht den bereits immensgroßen Bereich
der gesetzlichen bzw vertraglichen
Leistungen auf das Parlament soll
entscheiden wie die Mittel der
Steuerzahler eingesetzt werden Kollegen
Andrea gesagt nicht eine Regierung hält
sich ein Parlament sondern ein Parlament
hält sich eine Regierung die
Regierungskontrolle ist natürlich durch
das Parlament gewährt und natürlich
zuallererst am besten im Haushaltsrecht
lieber Kollege Martfeld das heißt das
heißt Wissenschaft wenn wir die Gesetz
wenn wir freiwillige Leistungen wenn wir
Maßnahmen Stichwort Demokratie leben
natürlich jetzt als gesetzliche
Maßnahmen festschreiben dann sind sie
natürlich der gestaltungsbefugnis des
Parlaments weitestgehend entzogen auch
das muss uns klar sein bei allen
Diskussionen die wir jetzt im nächsten
Jahr zu dem Demokratie im fördergesetz
eben führen werden eben gemeinsam mit
dem Plenum gerade im Hinblick auf die
Generation Gerechtigkeit wäre natürlich
eben diese aufbauschen
verantwortungslosen ich will auf
anziehen weisen Schulden von heute sind
die Steuern von Marken das geht
insbesondere an die Kollegen von der FDP
bitte gehen sie auf ihren Finanzminister
Christian Lindner nochmal zu und
versuchen Sie natürlich eben einen
möglichst eben nicht zu
schuldenträchtigen Haushalt auf dem Weg
zu bringen Kollege Fricke wird nachher
darüber sprechen und wird uns erzählen
wie man solide Haushalte hinbekommen
können vor einem halben Jahr hat sie FDP
noch gewusst ich hoffe Sie werden es
wieder lernen in dem Sinne wünsche ich
Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende gute
Haushaltsberatung und liebe Frau
Ministerin ich hoffe dass wir uns paar
Monaten auch zu anderen Themen noch
loben können alles Gute Gottes Segen
schönen Dank
paul lehrrieder war das für die
Unionsfraktion hat die Otto Fricke schon
angesprochen der wird gleich in der
Schlussrunde die erste Rede halten
allerdings haben wir noch zwei Redner in
dieser Debatte zum
Familienministerium
das Thema weil die Herren oft nur
dunkler Anzüge tragen so kann man nicht
so viel zu sagen als nächste Rednerin
erhält das Wort Jasmina kostet für die
SPD-Fraktion
und Jasmina Rostock ist die
Kinderbeauftragte der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Kinder und
Familienpolitik ist für unsere
SPD-Fraktion ein Herzstück unseres
politischen Handelns seit Jahren
seit Jahren kämpfen wir für einen
effektiven Kinderschutz und für die
Stärkung der Kinderrechte für bessere
Rahmenbedingungen für die Vereinbarkeit
von Familie und Beruf und dafür jedem
Kind die gleichen Chancen auf Bildung
Teilhabe und sozialen Aufstieg zu geben
wir haben bereits einiges erreicht und
ich freue mich dass wir in dieser
progressiven Koalition unseren
familienpolitischen Zielen weiter
Näherkommen werden
wir legen einen besonderen Schwerpunkt
auf das Elterngeld warum weil
Familienzeit wertvoll und wichtig ist
weil wir wollen dass ich auch Väter
stärker an der Betreuung von ihren
Kindern beteiligen
ich bin froh dass ich mein Mann dank
Elternzeit und Elterngeld um unseren
vier Monate alten Sohn kümmert während
ich hier zu Ihnen spreche das
Kinderbetreuung
das Kinderbetreuung nur Frauensache ist
muss endlich der Vergangenheit angehören
[Applaus]
weitere Schwerpunkte im Haushalt sind
das Kindergeld der Kinderzuschlag und
der Unterhaltsvorschuss
mit dem Unterhaltsvorschuss springt der
Staat ein und unterstützt Kinder von
Alleinerziehenden das ist gut und
richtig denn das Geld wird dringend
gebraucht aber es ist doch skandalös und
nicht hinnehmbar dass viele
Unterhaltspflichtige keinen in Unterhalt
für ihre Kinder bezahlen und sich so aus
ihrer Verantwortung stehlen
wir packen auch den Ausbau der
Ganztagsbetreuung an wenn Kinder in der
Schule ein warmes Mittagessen erhalten
bei ihren Hausaufgaben betreut werden
und gemeinsam spielen kurzum wenn alle
Kinder gute Bildungs- und
Betreuungsangebote von Anfang an
erhalten haben Sie die besten
Entwicklungschancen
ich möchte noch kurz auf ein Thema
eingehen dass mir sehr am Herzen liegt
der Schutz von Kindern und Jugendlichen
vor psychischer physischer und
sexualisierter Gewalt wir werden uns
dafür einsetzen dass die finanziellen
Mittel für den Kampf gegen sexualisierte
Gewalt entsprechend im Haushalt
hinterlegt werden denn wir wollen noch
entschiedener gegen Missbrauch und
Kinderpornografie Vorgehen wir wollen
diese Themen aus der Tabuzone holen und
das Schweigen brechen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit
diesem Haushalt geben wir Sicherheit im
Wandel denn in Kinder und Jugendliche
investieren heißt in unsere Zukunft zu
investieren packen wir es also an vielen
Dank
Jasmina Hostert war das hier zum
Haushalt 12,6 Milliarden Euro soll das
Bundesfamilienministerium bekommen im
Jahr 2022 und wir kommen zur letzten
Rednerin hier in dieser Debatte Leni
breymaier ist das sie ist die
familienpolitische Sprecherin der
Sozialdemokraten hier im Deutschen
Bundestag
schön dank frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Frau
Ministerinnen Spiegel
mir ist es eigentlich wurscht was sie
heute angezogen haben weil ich denke wir
sollten uns alle miteinander
insbesondere die Frauen nicht auf
Äußerlichkeiten reduzieren lassen aber
bitteschön
ich habe mir vorgenommen aus dem Feld
Familie Frauen Jugend und Seniorinnen
und Senioren ein Schlusspunkt zu setzen
mit dem Blick auf Seniorinnen und
Senioren und liebe Anne Jansen ich finde
dieser Koalitionsvertrag ist ja kein
Fortsetzungsroman und so lang ist er
nicht und wenn ich mir den Absatz
anschaue der zu Seniorinnen und Senioren
drin steht ist ja schon sehr gehaltvoll
und ich freue mich diese Dinge in den
nächsten Jahren da auch umsetzen zu
können und wenn ich schon gerade bei
ihnen bin liebe Kollegin wir waren
zusammen mit Ulli schaus und Nicole
Bauer in New York bei der unv und
Rechtskommission und das war wirklich
sehr erhellend dieses Thema Klimawandel
unter dem Blick
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit über mehrere
Tage auch zu betrachten heute kommt es
abschlussprotokoll und ich freue mich
außerordentlich dass die Union endlich
auch dafür ist wo in women finanziell
prima auszustatten dem schließen wir uns
sehr gerne an so und jetzt wieder zu den
Senioren und Senioren es ist ja so dass
diese 16,4 Prozent über 60-Jährige die
wir hier im Parlament haben das sind ja
nicht Menschen die mit dem vergleichbar
sind wie es ansonsten den alten in
Deutschland geht es fängt beim Einkommen
an und hört bei Fragen zur Einsamkeit
noch lange nicht auf ich freue mich dass
wir Sozialverbände haben die dieses
Thema wie geht es den alten in unserer
Gesellschaft aktiv angehen weil wenn die
AWO wenn die Malteser wenn andere das
Thema Einsamkeit Teilhabe betrachten
dann stärkt es den Sozialstaat und
gestärkt auch die
Demokratie bei uns und insbesondere
ältere sind auf Unterstützung angewiesen
um aus der sozialen Isolation
herauszukommen eine Studie des Deutschen
Zentrums für altersfragen hat dazu
festgestellt dass das
einsamkeitsempfinden 2020 noch deutlich
höher war als in den Jahren 2014 und
2017 und es war im ersten Jahr der
Pandemie liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
also da muss man schon auch tüchtig was
machen weil wir auch wissen soziale
Kontakte sind der Schlüssel zu
Gesundheit und zu Wohlbefinden ich hatte
kürzlich in meiner Bürger
bürgerinnensprechstunde einen Anruf von
einem alten Mann der hat mir gesagt ich
sei seit vier Tagen der erste Mensch mit
dem er redet entsprechend lang hat
dieses Gespräch gedauert aber wir müssen
noch gucken dass die Leute rauskommen
dass sie unter Leute kommen dass sie
dabei sind und insbesondere insbesondere
bei den über 80-Jährigen ist es normal
in ganz spannendes Thema
habe ich mit dem Replik auf die
Klamotten meine Redezeit verdummt
deshalb jetzt noch mal jetzt noch mal
zum Schluss ich freue mich auf die
Haushaltsberatungen ich freue mich dass
unsere Elisabeth Kaiser für diesen
Einzelplan alles geben wird vielen Dank
dafür Elisabeth und ich freue mich mit
der SPD-Fraktion auf die gemeinsame
Arbeit mit Ihnen liebe Frau Ministerin
und wir hoffen sehr dass sie bald wieder
vollständig gesund sind herzlichen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Leni breimeier weitere
Wortmeldungen zu diesem Einzelplan
liegenden nicht vor